well tonight we are continuing our
series on the state of the metro police
department
throughout the years several changes
have been made and that includes the
hiring process orco mana takes a closer
look at how metro chooses its officers
and what's being done to ensure there's
a respectful and diverse police force
it's a really rigorous process who
deserves to be behind the badge the las
vegas metropolitan police department
saying it leaves no stone unturned to
figure that out
i can't really stress enough how hard it
is that we work
to try to get the right people to wear
this uniform for every prospective
police officer metro conducts a major
background check
including a polygraph test and an up to
three hour psychological exam the
department also scours social media to
weed out the bad apples
if we see anything that is not
reflective of our values
they're not a candidate for employment
for example a recently rejected metro
applicant appeared in online photos
holding the confederate flag
how do we go about making sure we don't
have racist police officers
that question even more critical for
metro police now with racial tensions
reaching a boiling point in las vegas
over the summer
protests erupting throughout vegas
following the death of george floyd in
minneapolis
metro says one way to bridge the gap is
to bring more diversity to the
department
the latest numbers show only 10 percent
of all metro employees are black but the
department has ramped up minority
outreach in recent years
through the sheriff's african-american
hispanic and asian recruitment councils
and trying to increase demographics
throughout the
agency that mirror our own jurisdiction
that is going to be something that we'll
have to continually look at and assess
going into the future consulting expert
christina larusso says metro also needs
to work on improving the diversity of
its higher-ups
they need to be able to be heard and
know that their voice matters because
that will trickle down
to people wanting to be a part of the
force that are from minority communities
[Applause]
[Music]
but even among the smiling faces at
metro graduations the department knows
sometimes
bad apples are added to the basket
that's when the department's internal
affairs bureau steps in
with its early identification and
intervention program
we track every officer's statement
complaint every traffic action every
time the citizen makes a complaint to
get that officer to see what they're
doing
identify those patterns early on if we
identify that early on i can get that
information to a supervisor we're told
issues are addressed immediately just
like any other workplace you're going to
have people that don't belong and we
have a very high set of standards
metro says while it's made massive
strides there's still a lot of work to
do
the goal to have every officer who's
hired be a force for good
you have a duty to be
unbiased and to perform your work in a
way that
the community can trust orco mana 8 news
now
we have more information on police
hirings and firings department diversity
and
use of force policies all on
eightnewsnow.com
just click on the state of metro banner
right at the top of the page